Tuesday night, we were told that Donald Trump
was not going to be addressing the nation
about the strike
by Iran on two American bases in Iraq. But
yesterday Donald Trump did address the nation
and it was a bizarre, rambling, confused,
dishonest speech. But the one upside to the
speech is that it does seem Donald Trump is
not planning to immediately escalate with
Iran into a full scale war. We should all
be happy about that. Now, before we get into
this, especially because there's some stuff
in the speech that's funny in the way that
Trump sometimes makes us laugh so that we
don't cry, but this is very serious stuff.
People's lives are on the line here. People's
lives are also on the line with healthcare
and immigration and many issues, but they're
on the line here in a very specific way. We
are a laughing stock with this guy as the
president, and we don't want to forget the
seriousness of this even when we watch the
wacky parts here. So let's start with Donald
Trump's opening line, which is Iran will never
have nuclear weapon
as long as I'm president of the United States.
Irfan will never be allowed to have a nuclear
weapon.
Now we're all thrilled that no one was harmed,
but it is sort of a strange place to start
and the big thing that the Trumpists are pointing
to in this speech is that Donald Trump says
Iran is standing down.
Our great American forces are prepared for
anything. Iran appears to be standing down,
which is a good thing for all parties concerned
and a very good thing for the world. No American
or Iraqi lives were lost because of the precautions
taken. The disbursal of forces and an early
warning system that worked very well,
right wingers are loving this because to them
Donald Trump saying Iran is standing down
is a sign that Donald Trump has won, that
Trump is the alpha that Trump has dominated
Iran because he says Iran is standing down.
Now of course this is very much in the eye
of the beholder. Trump killed general Kaseem
Solemani Iran bomb two bases and both parties
are now saying, if you don't keep going, we
won't keep going. It's not exactly standing
down, but the Trump is sort of claiming some
kind of weird victory when in reality, there
are no winners here. Certainly not here in
the United States where Donald Trump is still
president. Now let's get to a part of the
statement by Donald Trump. It is sort of hard
to hear and understand Trump, uh, often in
the speech because of the amount of sniffing
I read that he sniffed 85 times during the
speech, something was going on with his nose.
But try to understand what Trump says here.
Iran's hostilities substantially increased
after the foolish Iran nuclear deal was signed
in 2013 and they were given $150 billion,
not to mention one point $8 billion in cash.
So he's blaming Obama of course, but this
hundred and 50 billion that Iran was given
is a farce. It's far less than that. That's
been fact checked. But the real moment that
I want to get to in the blame Obama, part
of the speech is this next one.
The missiles fired last night at us and our
allies were paid for with the funds made available
by the last administration. The regime also
greatly tightened the reins on their own country.
Even recently killing 1,500 people at the
many protests
paid for with funds made available by the
Obama administration. That is extremely coy
language and deceptive language. It was a
rainy and money that we had put a hold on
and the hold was released as part of the nuclear
deal. It's extraordinarily disingenuous and
deceptive to say that that that in any way
was the U S giving Iran money. That's like
saying if you owe someone $100 but you're
holding the a hundred dollars and you give
it to them and then they go and take that
a hundred bucks and buy drugs to say you are
responsible for them. Buying drugs is a stretch.
It's a very childish notion. You were holding
the money for them. Now Trump is putting in
place immediate sanctions on Iran. He says
that amid more of this constant sniffing,
we continue to evaluate options in response
to Iranian aggression. The United States will
immediately impose additional punishing economic
sanctions on the Iranian regime. These powerful
sanctions will remain until around changes
its behavior in recent months alone around
as sea ships and international waters fired
an unprovoked strike on Saudi Arabia and shot
down to us drones.
And then of course maybe the biggest news,
and this is something we should be glad about
and I'll talk later about the context of this.
Donald Trump does not appear to be escalating
offering sort of an olive olive branch to
Iran. In the shared goal of the destruction
of ISIS,
al-Baghdadi was trying again to rebuild the
ISIS caliphate and failed. Tens of thousands
of ISIS fighters have been killed or captured
during my administration. ISIS is a natural
enemy of Iran. The destruction of ISIS is
good for Iran and we should work together
on this and other shared priorities. Finally,
to the people and leaders of Iran, we want
you to have a future and a great future, one
that you deserve. One of prosperity at home,
in harmony with the nations of the world.
And then one Donald Trump off the rails moment
again being called to everything from a a
sign of a neurological issue to who knows
what Donald Trump mentions. Accomplishment,
accompliment shades, accompliment shades.
Not sure if that's a window dressing or a
political outcome. Take a look.
Over the last three years under my leadership,
our economy is stronger than ever before in
America's achieved energy independence. These
historic accomplishments shades our strategic
priorities. These are accomplishments that
nobody thought were possible.
Very odd moment. So overall, the speech was
filled with Donald Trump's lies, blaming Obama,
shirking responsibility, false claims of success.
But it does seem that Iran is ploy in a sense
worked. Iran retaliated. They got a response
to the assassination of Kaseem Solemani on
the record, but they gave Donald Trump a way
out. Trump also believes that he won. He got
Kaseem Sola Mani. Iran retaliated but didn't
kill anybody. So is this all good? Well, the
X factor is that Donald Trump wants all of
this to help him get reelected, to distract
from impeachment. If nothing else happens,
the conversation goes right back to Donald
Trump being an impeached president to Donald
Trump as a vulnerable incumbent president.
That's where we are today. We should all be
glad that it appears as though there's not
going to be a further escalation, but what
I want to talk about later today and we're
going to talk about next is the fact that
Trump backed away from a problem he created
can't be seen as an administration.
This is like taking credit for putting out
a fire that you started. I think it was Bernie
Sanders who use that metaphor and that's what
I want to talk about next.